I'm Steve Kearns and I'm the District Advancement Chair with the Portola District in North Orange County, California.
This addition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me
And now the old Scoutmaster.
This just in from Troop 1882, where my friend Jen Chaplin is involved.
At a recent Scout parent meeting in preparation for summer camp,
one of the older Scouts was talking about summer camp and things like that
And he said: you know, being thrifty- a Scout is thrifty-
Does not mean you go to the trading post and buy your body weight in Skittles.
Just under your body weight, please. maybe 10 pounds,
That's plenty.
Can any summer camp function without Skittles?
That's a question to ponder.
Hey, this is podcast number 226..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Greg Curtis is the Scoutmaster of Troop 149 in Jamestown, North Dakota.
Greg, I'm pretty sure this is my first contact with anybody in North Dakota.
I think I talk with a couple of people about canoeing up there.
But anyways, Greg wrote in to say
after years of struggling, pushing, pulling and being just plain frustrated with my troop,
I really decided to give it up.
It wasn't until I found ScoutmasterCG. I found a renewed energy for Scouts.
I love the info and all that you provide for us cat herders
Here in the great wide open.
Thanks again.
Well, thank you, Greg, for getting in touch
And I'm glad we were able to be helpful to you.
I think that's great,
As I have been doing over the past couple of weeks,
open up the chat feature at ScoutmasterCGcom
And if the chat feature isn't open, if it's not live,
you can leave me a message. Jim did
And he said congrats on podcast number 225..
That number is near and dear to my heart, being from Anaheim Council- Troop 225.
And I thought that's a great idea.
I should really start announcing that each podcast is dedicated to the troop, pack
and crew of the corresponding number.
So today's podcast is dedicated to pack 226 and troop 226 and crew 226
and not to leave out the sea scouts, ship 226.
And we don't want to leave out the varsity scouts.
So team 226.
And there you go.
I had a nice discussion with Steve, who is from pack 3623 in Michigan,
And he was talking about being the cub master and kind of effectively the
den leader and the committee chair and whatever else for his pack,
Because getting parents to be at meetings wasn't that difficult,
but actually getting them to take on a role was-
And we discussed that for a little bit. just to boil down what my advice
would be in that kind of situation.
You may find that people are going to be reluctant to take on a title
or a role, but they're perfectly happy taking on a task.
If you look at all the titles that you need- committee chair, blah,
blah, blah, blah- and you break those titles into tasks
and ask folks, they will usually take on the tasks.
And then you know, after they've taken on a few of the tasks,
they look at the title and they're saying, oh, it's really not that hard.
But titles like committee chair, that's very open ended commitment.
A task is something that has a beginning and a middle in the end
That can get people through the door and then make them into good,
solid volunteers.
And when you're talking about volunteering, it's kind of the
way of the world that a lot of people do double, triple,
four-pole duty as volunteers.
I think actually in each community there are maybe a hundred,
maybe 50 volunteers and they spend most of their times
in meetings for different things, because you keep running
into the same people over and over again, don't you?
I'm in a pretty small town and I know if I go to any
meeting of volunteers there's predictable three people that
I'm going to meet there that are involved with everything.
So anyway, it was good to chat with you, Steve.
Keep an eye on the chat feature at scoutmastercgcom.
I'll post a notice that it's live and we can spend a little time chatting
Over on the blog. last week, let's see,
One of the posts that we put up right after the podcast last week
was some troop meeting ideas, just in case you're stuck
in a troop meeting rut.
I introduced a new weekly feature with some scouting video pics.
Man, there's just so much interesting stuff out there-
so much interesting information, instructional stuff
And also what I think is really kind of cool are videos of
Scouts and other parts of the world,
And this past week I posted a video from Scouts in India.
It's kind of a music video and it's a really well done video.
Make sure you take a look at it.
Our big infographic for this week was Ten Essentials
for Camping and that was pretty well received,
And I'm offering all of the infographics that we've produced
over the past couple of years all put together
as PDF files in the Scoutmaster CG PDF package.
So make sure you go to the website and check that out.
This week our Greenbar Life author, Enoch Hyze,
did a great article on diffusing explosive situations,
And the Greenbar Life articles are intended for your youth leadership.
Enoch is now an assistant scoutmaster,
but he's young enough to remember what it was like
to be a youth leader and offer some really great advice
for youth leaders.
So send them our way and look for the Greenbar Life features
at scoutmastercgcom,
Just like the video pics. I hope to post a quiz every week
because quizzes are fun.
I really enjoy doing them
And this week I put one up with 10 different knots
and a lot of people knew all 10 knots.
They're pretty common knots.
They're scouting knots for up to first class
and a couple of them get involved
with pioneering merit badge there,
So they should be pretty familiar to you.
If you haven't taken the quiz yet, go ahead
and you can get a little badge to tell everybody
how great you are. that you can put it on Twitter
or on your Facebook feed.
And then just yesterday we had our weekly entry
from Baden Powell's blog, which was some thoughts
on discipline.
And go check that out, because it's not what you would think
it would be because of the title.
Very interesting take on the subject of discipline
from our founder sort of Robert Baden Powell.
We'll hear from him a little later too.
Let's see what else is going on.
Well, I know a couple of thousand of you have the
Scoutmaster CG app and it's a great way to keep
the resources we create at your fingertips
on your mobile device,
And you can get it on iTunes or on Google Play,
depending on if you are a member of the Apple tribe
or the Android tribe.
And before we move on, I want to make sure to take
the time to thank Michael Strong, who signed up
as a ScoutmasterCGcom backer this week.
If you haven't heard of it, we have a backer program
and the funds that we get from backers go towards
the expenses of producing and publishing the podcast,
the blog post and all the stuff that we're able
to keep freely available for Scouters all over the world.
Go check that out.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom,
Click the support link right there at the top
of the page and you can join the growing number
of Scouters who are quite generously becoming backers
and helping make all this possible.
Well, in this week's podcast- good old number 226,
in Scoutmastership, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk about the Scouter as a guide
and three types of leaders,
And then I've got an email question to answer
and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we
Scoutmastership- in seven minutes or less,
Now, any Scouter, anybody working with youth,
at one minute may be a coach
at next. they may be instructor.
a little later on they may be a counselor
or a manager, or a leader or a trainer.
The common thread woven to all these roles
is the spirit of a helpful guide.
Let me contrast two different types of guides.
Imagine a bus tour of some important city somewhere
and we're seated in the air-conditioned comfort
of a motor coach and we roll along.
the guide explains each landmark in detail
so we don't miss anything.
In fact, there's so much explaining-
and you know how, if you've ever been
on one of those tours before.
the guide's on a script and there's a lot of explaining
and there's not a whole lot of time left for questions,
and we sit there and we listen attentively
and we dutifully turn our heads to the left
and to the right and then the tour is over.
Now contrast that tour with a hike
guided by a knowledgeable outdoors guide,
Our group takes the lead and finds the trail.
where the trail branches,
The guide will tell us which way to go
if we can't figure it out on our own.
He doesn't mind if we stop now and again
and we admire a flower or take in the view,
and he'll happily tell us what we're looking at
if we ask. but he's not going to push us along,
He's going to let us take our own pace
And though the guide may drop a hint here and there,
he's going to volunteer very little information.
We may miss some sites along the way
or we may pass by interesting things,
but we will probably get more out
of what we discovered on the hike
than the things that the tour guide
told us about on the bus.
Do you see what I mean?
Like the guide,
scouts are more responsive
than directive.
We inspire and encourage scouts
to explore and learn at their own speed.
Guiding scouts is more of a gentle push
in the right direction,
more of a suggestion rather than a command,
more of a question asked
rather than an answer given.
We can better understand
that special kind of leadership required
to be a good guide
in three different leadership styles,
And to do that
I want to read you two quotes.
The first is from Baden Powell,
the founder of Scouting.
He said
leadership is the key note to success.
but leadership is difficult to define
And leaders are difficult to find.
I frequently stated that
any man can be a commander
and a trained man may often
make an instructor,
but a leader is more like a poet,
not manufactured.
The second quote I want to read you
is a very old quote from Laosu.
The best leader
is one that people are
barely aware of.
The next best is one who is
loved and praised by the people.
Next comes one
who is feared.
Worst is one who is despised.
If the leader does not have
enough faith in his people,
they will have no faith in him.
He puts great value in words
and says little,
so that when his work is finished
the people all say:
we did it ourselves.
Now, Baden Powell and Laosu
lived on opposite sides of the world
and wrote centuries apart.
but they both describe
three distinct leadership styles
And you know I'm going to define
some styles here. but it doesn't mean
that we're not going to define
some aspect of all three styles.
but the first style of leadership
is authoritarian leadership.
This is Laosu's feared leader
and Baden Powell's commander
I can remember as a young director
of a program department
at our summer camp
I was kind of insufferable
and authoritarian.
I was certainly demanding.
I wasn't particularly friendly
and I mistook my kind of abrasive personality
for clarity of mission.
I was brash
in the editorial
and I really wonder that any of the counselors
that were working for me lasted through the summer.
I did get my comeuppance
at the end of the season
when one of them had the sand
to write exactly what he thought
of me and my job
in his evaluation at the end of the year,
And since then I've always considered
that I have owed him
a great debt of gratitude
because it gave me a chance
to look at myself and it changed me for the better.
Authoritarian leaders
do get things done,
but our goal as
scouters is much broader
than just efficiently completing tasks.
Scouting has well defined
expectations, but these
are not enforced in an
obedience oriented,
authoritarian manner.
We want our scouts to be obedient,
but we don't want them to be frightened.
What we want to do is encourage them to ask questions
and find their own direction
and then respond by helping them
find the answers to make things
happen. The second kind
of leader I want to talk about
is what I would call a permissive leader.
Lao Zhu called this
the despised leader.
Let's correspond this with
Baden Powell's trained man.
And what I mean by a permissive leader
is when I was hired to coach
a middle school soccer team
decades ago, I was
young enough to remember authoritarian
coaches and teachers that I really
didn't like,
And I resolved I would be the kind
of coach everybody liked-
The cool coach, the cool teacher.
I traded the discipline
and authority a coach
needs to have
for currying favor with the team, and the result was
a real mess.
If you're a teacher or a coach out there
and you've had a similar experience, you're laughing right now
because you know exactly what I'm talking about.
What my players needed was a coach,
and
a coach who would give them structure and discipline.
They didn't need another friend.
They already had plenty of friends.
Permissive leaders: they're not
usually very sure of themselves
and they look for reassurance in the approval
and friendship of their followers.
For all their effort, permissive leaders
don't earn respect or friendship.
More often than not, they end up
with people laughing at them behind their backs
in the way that Lao Zhu describes.
Now the third type of leader
is a responsive leader.
This is Lao Zhu's
leader that the people are
barely aware of,
and what Baden Powell called
a poet.
Responsive leadership is really kind of this
barely perceptible influence
that empowers people to do things
for themselves, By listening more than
talking, because,
remember, Lao Zhu said that this type
of leader values words and
uses them infrequently.
By exercising goodwill
and having an unshakable faith
in the people that were leading,
responsive leaders can create
an atmosphere of shared accomplishment
And, rather than dictating
their own wishes, responsive leaders
inspire others
to adopt high expectations.
Their example of service
is a powerful motivational
force. In difficulty,
they're going to respond
not with authoritarianism,
but with empathy and compassion.
Now I'll tell you, after many
fits and starts and years of trying,
I do actually find myself
being a responsive leader
more often than not. I know there's
still plenty of room for improvement,
but if I trade the kind of self
aggrandizing authority
and my desire to be appreciated
for an honest aspiration
to serve other people, I am happier,
and so are my scouts.
My ideal scouter practices
this kind of responsive leadership,
enabling scouts to do things for themselves
while offering an appropriate
amount of direction to assure they remain
safe and they get the most out of scouting.
I knew I could do. I knew I could do.
I knew I could do. I knew I could do, I knew I could do.
I need a letter.
send it by name
Email. that is, folks.
and here's an answer to one of your
emails.
So I got this really interesting email this week
and it started out by saying
our troop is doing summer camp this year
with two other troops and I thought,
wow, that's going to be cool. A relatively
small summer camp experience,
kind of one that the troops are doing
on their own. I think that's a really cool idea.
And then the author said
I'm in charge of 10 or so scouts
who will be attending my classes.
and I thought, uh oh,
classes. well, we need to
talk about that. I'm wondering
if you have or know
of a resource that outlines
a teaching curriculum for tender foot
through first class rank
in a week. and I said, uh oh,
we're going to have to do
some thinking here. So in my reply
this is what I wrote- I said:
now you're going to summer camp, right,
we're not going to school.
we have schedules and teaching and tests
and reading assignments and classes and
curriculums. We're at camp,
so let's keep it camping.
So what happens when we go camping?
if you look at the requirements up to first class
rank, that's what happens.
that's what scouts do. We don't
hold classes and work on requirements.
scouts go camping
and in the course of camping,
they do things that complete the
requirements. This is really kind of a
deceptively simple distinction,
but one that's so important in scouting
and we all too
frequently miss this. This isn't just
some semantic nicety
of actually having classes, but calling
them something different. This is for real.
what opportunities
ought to be able for scouts at summer camp?
well, take a look at the requirements.
that's what needs to be available.
you're going to pitch some tents and some
tarps. you're going to plan, prepare and clean
up after a meal. you're going to take a hike, play
a game, build a tower, go swimming.
that's what scouts do. are you following
me? do you get it? it's not a list
of requirements. it's what you do when
you go camping. so let's take our
10 scouts and meet with them
in the morning and say: today you're going to build a fire
and cook your lunch. now, what do you need to
build a fire? what safety concerns do you
have? what tools are you going to need? do you know how to use
the tools? what kind of wood is going
to work best. how much do you need?
do you know how to cook in a Dutch oven?
do you think there's anything in the scout
handbook that would help you figure things out?
I'll tell you what, guys. I'll be back
in an hour with the food. I want
to leave in about five or ten minutes, so give me
a list of what you need. while I'm gone,
you guys figure out how to get a fire
set up, get the wood, get everything
you need and have everything ready
to light when I get back and I'll bring
the matches and then we'll
have lunch and then you go away
and let them at it. they have a scout handbook.
they have a bunch of questions to ask.
they have a task to do. they're going
to figure it out. they might get it right,
they might get it wrong, it doesn't really
matter. they're camping and they're
having fun. they're hanging out with their
buddies and they're learning. so you're
going to get back and you're going to take a look
and maybe there's a couple of corrections to be made
or maybe there's a little bit of knowledge to fill in
a lot of times. that is going to be taken
care of by asking more questions.
so, guys, how did that go? did you figure
things out? who did what?
where did you learn how to do that?
are you having trouble? get it started?
what would you stop doing or start
doing to make things work better? do you see
what I mean? and then you can cook lunch
and so you make whatever corrections
there need to be made or modifications
to what they've done.
we haven't sat them down and taught them
anything for even 30 seconds,
much less sat them down and had a class
with a curriculum involved.
the next day, let's say
we're going to go swimming. what should you be
thinking of? is there anything in the scout
handbook that may that you may want to know
about going swimming? what kind of an area
do you need for swimming? should there be
a lifeguard? see what I'm saying.
the next day, you can say: today
we're going on a hike. what do you need to bring?
where are we going? how will we get there?
do you need a map and compass?
did you bring one with you? do you know how
to use a map and compass together? does the
scout handbook say anything about using a map
and compass? I'll tell you what
I have- some things to do, and in an hour
I'll meet you at this spot that I've
marked right here on the map. do you guys have
any questions? so, instead of sitting
down and having a class and a curriculum
and a plan, let's
go camping and do the things
that scouts do. and then you know what's
going to happen: is, at one
point, the lights going to go on and one of the
scouts is going to ask you: you know, we went on
that hike, is that a requirement for
tenderfoot? and you can say: well, I don't
know. did you check tenderfoot? let's take a
look here. which requirement? do you think
that it is? read the requirement to me?
do you think that you met that requirement?
and now they're getting self motivated
because they've discovered: oh, these
things that we're doing, they're in the
book and they actually meet requirements,
and all I have to do is ask about them
and if I've done them, I can get them
signed off. and if I haven't really done
them, well, now I know how to
work on that. so, no classes,
please, just go camping.
no handouts, no forms
or charts or papers. a scout
has a handbook. that's all he needs.
you might want to have, maybe like a
central bulletin board with some posters,
some information, but let's not have any
paperwork. okay, we're camping
and the other thing I would say is: you
said that you're going to work with ten
scouts, and that's great. you might break
them into patrols of five or they may
stay as one big patrol. it's kind of up
to them. but let's remember that scouts
do things in patrols, not in a big herd.
if there's more than eight or ten
guys, that's two patrols doing things
far enough apart so they don't
interfere with each other. start
with the challenge in the action. you
know. I gave you some examples: cooking
lunch or going on a hike or going
swimming. ask the questions,
especially where can you find
out what you need to know, and let
them go, let them try these things out,
then reflect on what they've done
and maybe explain a few things
that they may have missed. now.
is this going to take more time than
sitting them down in a class? well, of course
it will. will they get all of the
requirements up to first class? I doubt it.
by the end of the week they'll have
one really important thing:
they will have learned how to
learn and how to motivate themselves.
every time you find yourself
teaching or explaining something,
stop and start asking
questions so the scouts can
find the answers for themselves. every
time the action stops and the scouts
are sitting there listening to you
talk, stop and get them active
again. and I would say also,
not everything you do for a week at
summer camp needs to be advancement: build,
start or go fishing or climb a tree
or play a game or take a nap
or wander around or hang out
with your buddies. it's camp,
we're at camp, and camp is a great
place to do all of these things.
my final thought for you is:
Bayden Powell said that advancement
is like a suntan. it's something
that you get when you are in the
outdoors. scouts don't join
scouting to be in classes
and follow curriculums and
earn badges. they join
to do cool stuff with their friends
and they learn things and earn
badges as a result of the
things that they do. so have a great
time at summer camp, but remember
it's not school, it's summer camp
and there should be a lot of fun involved
and your goal is
scouts going home having learned
how to learn for themselves
music.
thank you for listening to this
226th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch.
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, like thousands of others, you can
subscribe to receive updates by email.
you can get the scoutmaster app on
google play or the itunes app store,
as I mentioned earlier. and, of course,
there is the vast panorama
of social media
outlets. you can join the
5800 folks who like scoutmaster blog
on facebook, tweet along with the
chorus of 1060
tweeters on twitter, pin the
portrait in his pictures, proffered
publicly, with 1500 other prolific
pinners on Pinterest.
and you can watch us, if you dare,
at scoutmastercg on youtube.
and there's always the opportunity
to join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive scoutmaster
circle on google plus.
now, listen, if you can't face facebook,
if twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in pinterest,
if you don't put the? u in youtube,
if you are a minus when it comes
to google plus, don't worry, buggy,
you can zoom into the late 90s
and email me. that's right,
send me an email. I'm
clarkgreen at clark
at scoutmastercgcom,
clark
at
scoutmastercgcom.
and before we
go, I want to remind you the
scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor they endorsed or sponsored by the
Boy Scouts of America or anyone else-
any other scouting organization in the world
for that matter. no, it's just me
talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Bell.
Good luck to you and good camping.
Oh, I thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.